well the symbol of the Republican Party
of course is the elephant and it has
been since Abraham Lincoln was president
yet for much of the last century the
national media have advocated for a
different animal mascot for the GOP the
tiger always ever said that explicitly
out loud but according to a review we
did of 85 years of headlines from the
Washington Post to the New York Times
America's biggest newspapers believe
that the Republican Party behaves very
much like a predatory jungle cat there's
not really a crazy comparison when you
think about you can kind of see the
resemblance Republicans tend to avoid it
densely populated areas their senses
come alive at night their leader is
orange but above all they pounce
according to The Times in the post
Republicans are compulsive bouncers
fangs bared claws extended they leap
with feline precision and devour they
can't help themselves their victims are
usually unsuspecting woodland creatures
who never see it coming
crouching high in the branches
Republicans land on their prey from
above then mercilessly tear them to
shreds sometimes just for sport its
grizzly Republicans did it to Alexandria
Acacio Cortes just the other day no word
on how she's doing she must have been
terrified at the very least that
certainly had the media looking it's
done then just a few weeks before that
and two weeks before that Republicans
pounced on some poor congresswoman from
Michigan apparently she made the mistake
of walking alone on Capitol Hill at
night r.i.p and then there's someone
before that conservatives somehow
managed to pounce inside the vatican
that's in rome it's a long way from
washington republican hunting grounds
appear to be more extensive than
previously understood some victims have
endured multiple republican pounces and
lived to tell the tale hillary clinton
for example God knows how many pounces
she's had to repeal tough lady Barack
Obama to his eight years in Washington
and matter to a single uninterrupted
Republican pounced imagine the horror of
that no wonder you don't see him much
anymore he's still recover
all those claw marks to fill what's
remarkable is how long Republicans have
been doing this pouncing on people
here's a New York Times headline from
February 15 1933 FDR had not even been
inaugurated yet and already those
Republicans were pouncing on him
hard to believe Roosevelt made it three
full terms pouncing then pouncing now
apparently a tiger does not change his
stripes